la neige a fait son grand retour ce
mardi 22 janvier dans les yvelines entre
1 et 5 cm sont tombées dans la matinée
sur le département
cette saison c'est bah ouais faut pas
que ça continue trop mais bon bah c'est
comme ça quoi bon marché oui pour
marcher sur alger nommé jadot jeu ça du
hautbois à moi d'autres au contraire
n'était pas aussi enthousiaste c'est
très très compliqué c'est très dur
enfin on n'arrive pas à avancer fin du
coup c'est un peu le bordel faut aller
fois les failles très doucement fonds
faut faire attention reçoit il ya cessé
ça glisse beaucoup faut faire attention
aux freins faut pas freiner fort faut
freiner tout doucement
des recommandations qui s'appliquaient
également aux voitures certains
automobilistes illinois n'ont pas pu
éviter les dérapages dans les virages le
trafic était notamment difficile sur les
petits axes routiers 1 ça glisse
beaucoup je viens juste de versailles là
et à 10 alors ça va pour rendre la
circulation la plus praticable possible
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines 12 déneigeuses ont réalisé
chacune entre 30 et 40 km d'intervention
sur les routes
les opérations ont débuté à partir de 11
heures après une première sortie de
prévention dans la nuit c'est un joueur
exceptionnel puisqu'en s'attendait pas à
autant de neige ça sans qu'il nous il
faut qu'on puisse déneiger pendant que
les véhicules ne soient pas là donc
c'est pour ça forcément en détermine des
fois des tranches horaires qui sont
peut-être pas comprise par la population
mais en fait on prend des trans horaire
c'est tout simplement pour pouvoir
déneiger pendant qu'ils aient moins de
circulation et les déneigeuses devrait
de nouveau sortir dans les prochaines
heures de nouvelles chutes de neige sont
attendues dans la nuit